governments around the world and donors
are spending millions of dollars in
increasing the opportunities for
education and improving the quality of
education and these governments need to
know what are the strategies that work
and because they only have limited
resources they need to know what is cost
effective now a new wave of economics
research is using randomized control
trials just like those that are used in
medicine to answer these questions how
do we get kids in school and how do we
improve their learning while they're
there in our article for science we
summarize the results from this
literature and in particular we look at
the comparative cost effectiveness of
over 30 programs that were tested
through randomized control trials where
the outcome is test scores in primary
schools in developing countries and what
we find is strikingly similar patterns
across countries and many of these
results in these lessons challenge
conventional wisdom it's perhaps not
surprising that economics plays an
important role in the demand for
education if you reduce the costs of
schooling or if you provide cash
transfers conditional on children going
to school then you will increase the
number of children going to school was
more surprising is that even small
changes in costs can have big impacts on
behavior so a program in Malawi provided
cash transfers to families if their
children went to school now those cash
transfers varied from ten dollars a
month to five dollars a month there was
really no difference in attendance in
those two different categories another
example is a program in Kenya that
provided free school uniforms to
children now these uniforms cost just
eight dollars and yet providing this
uniform increased school attendance by 3
percentage points now eight dollars is
small compared to the cost of educating
of child is also small
if you think about a family weighing all
the costs and all the benefits of
Education that eight dollars would
change that decision is kind of
surprising it's also potentially
surprising the one of the most
cost-effective ways of increasing access
to education as a health program
treating children for parasitic worms in
Kenya led to a twenty-five percent
reduction in absenteeism rates for
children it increased the rate at which
girls passed the school leaving exam and
ten years later it was increasing
productivity of those children now in
the workforce much recent work has
focused on improving the quality of
education and the quality of education
in many of these countries is really
very poor we see very high class sizes
teachers are absent a lot there are very
few suppliers like textbooks in the
classroom and children know very little
even if they're going to school quite
regularly increasing these inputs having
more teachers more tax books and even
giving schools flexible grants that they
can spend as they like had no impact on
task off the research suggests a number
of reasons why more of the same doesn't
seem to be effective one of them is that
children have such a basic level of
learning in these countries that they're
falling behind the curricula so when you
provide text books to children for
example those who score highly on the
initial exam benefit but the vast
majority of children can't learn
properly from the textbooks now a number
of programs have been designed to tailor
the level of teaching to the level of
the child to address this problem one
program in India for example assess
which children were falling behind and
took them out of the class and provided
basic remedial education and that was
very effective another program provided
math software which allow children to
learn at their own pace and finally a
program in Kenya provided additional
contract teachers which allowed the
schools to reduce class size to divide a
large class into two with two different
teachers now simply reducing class size
had no impact but when those classes
were divided based on the level of
learning of the child the program was
quite effective the second lesson is the
teacher accountability as critical as
I've said many teachers are absent from
school in developing countries and one
approach to this was to link pay to
whether teachers show up no program in
India was very effective it had teachers
take a picture of themselves at the
beginning and end of the day and then
their pay was linked to whether or not
they showed up to school and that
increased teacher attendance it also
increased the test scores of the
children I think what's critical here is
you've got to design the teacher
incentive program effectively you have
to worry about teaching to the test and
you have to worry about teachers
supervisors undermining the incentive
program now all of this research is
starting to change the way that
investments in developing countries are
made in education I talked about the
deworming program earlier this is now
being scaled up to across the whole of
Kenya and a number of Indian states are
taking on math school-based deworming
over 40 million children now are
dewormed through schools largely as a
result of this research I think the next
challenges are to look at pre-primary
and post primary education have this
huge wave of children completing primary
school in developing countries and
that's fantastic but these children are
now looking for the opportunity to move
on to secondary education
the system simply aren't there to cope
with it we have to find a way of
providing secondary education in a way
that is effective and that these
countries can afford
you